greetings my friends and welcome to a
dummy Christmas review this holiday
season that they gave the greatest death
camp team has decided to give me
something very special for Christmas a
room very few people know this but where
I do my reviews is actually just a wall
what wall the other three are missing
he's very cool to kiss their wall I mean
would it kill you guys just two guys
very more why did I think this today
we're going to look at a very special
Christmas classic I am of course talking
about a Christmas story there's this boy
named Ralphie who's sort of like the
Wonder Years kid if he was a Hitler
Youth and he wants what any innocent
child at Christmas once an armed weapon
with the ability to harm small animals
but Ralphie's mother is very much
against getting this device by commonly
coining the phrase you shoot your eye
out
I wouldn't shut my eye out once he was a
Korean store owner who had to take my BB
gun away oh my why did you have to be so
cruel
Ref he goes and a series of mini
adventures including going to school
going to the Lord
looking for a Christmas tree actually
this is an unbelievably boring story I
mean the big point attention in the
movie is that he says the f-word why do
so many people still start a flame war
whenever somebody says the word furry he
also meets a very terrifying Santa Claus
sort of like if the Cowardly Lion ate
that god thing from Star Trek 5 and even
he says he will not get a PB gun but at
the end of the day Ralphie still does
get his BB gun
and shoots his eye out boy what side to
the gun control argue me is this movie
on but it turns out Ralphy doesn't shoot
his eye out he only destroys his glasses
and thankfully he has an extra pair this
was the most exciting part of the climax
aside from the part when they had to go
and get Chinese food
that part was riveting almost as for
everything is getting Korean food I was
just aiming it at your pet ferret what
you were going to eat anyway now you
have to walk with a small bruise on your
anus and your left butt cheek terms of
the lower than the other but in the end
the Christmas story does have a very
positive ending but we discovered that
they are making a Christmas Story - and
the makers are surely going to have this
is chittery buzzing don't go away
Christmas I want to stay in this robe